hello and welcome to video playing our
Vth what am I going to do
okay we have to practice this opening of
it again they declined
they all have bought my repertoire No
okay so this Spanish Spanish for Knights
against castles oh shoot
I think I'm canceling him
in such a long time that I looked into
that and now I think 94 is right I just
wonder if he takes e5 but I have just
six not that it's not a good idea
yeah 95 d 693 Bishop g4 something like
that okay I know it will probably take I
should be for you don't want to see
really on the board I can take with the
pawn by the way that maybe I should have
thought about it for a moment longer the
journey speaking black is quite okay
here now the knight on c6 is traded it
often doesn't feel that great anyway and
that doesn't look dangerous Bishop g5 I
wonder now I don't really wonder if he
goes Bishop H for our play g5 there is
no way around that
I'm sorry we should be three maybe
something solid what is taking a long
time in this position which is not
really all that exciting okay so and now
I am to take on this is maybe an idea
actually why not
it's a tempo and then Queen h4 might
provoke some weaknesses you almost don't
have to take so m92 Queen h4 or is that
actually not working Queen h4 h 395
night XD form maybe this is a whole
whole bunch of nonsense
Bishop takes a three pawn takes Queen
chicks
you cannot move the night to probably
works okay and then just covered
coverage age three probably sending me
back
yeah 95 not sure f4 is dangerous really
it's tough the same
you're going to push f4 maybe I know
what he's doing is absolutely spending
even more time than I usually do Knight
f4
and shortage does
I get to meet the Queen
it is it is equal very equal ish
yeah this is the way to do this blunder
full exchange not easy to lose this
position actually oh that's pretty
pretty awful move Quincy three night
only five will be tough to win against
white is still a lot better of course
but it's not takes it takes a bit of
technical precision I guess to win
okay that is closed down now the only
way for him to win now would be to push
pawns the question is is age five good
Jean okay he's not going to play age
four I can play G for King g3 and age
four
this is a possible way forward
that's not easy to say really if I
should do this it's got rock edge for
coming
it's 4g64
[Music]
maybe I'm getting super smart somehow
they losing on time that would be funny
what must have been something that's a
nice gift probably some sort of
connection glitch yeah it said a draw I
don't know it shouldn't be at all but
it's not totally impossible
yeah I think not much what's happening
is the whole time until I blended the
exchange really yeah here I wanted to
originally play Queen h4 but that
doesn't work I think age 3 95 94 and
then I was thinking here but it doesn't
work Queen e2 I thought ok rupee 1 is
even stronger between e2 is enough so
that didn't work and I'm mostly
interested if I had a fortress they are
not and that is of course extremely
stupid just long during this but Queen D
3 Queen g3 is apps that's really bad and
totally unnecessary right why did he do
that kill his own pawn structure there
am i threatening something here maybe
I'm not understanding it right midnight
h5 there's cream g4 I don't really think
I have a threat here Queen d1s the
engine but it also gives this I mean we
create maybe
soon
I mean this is this is certainly winning
for white because here the queenside is
not close to you can do something like
yeah just reposition the rooks and get
the King over here like here here and
then slowly open this up that should win
but the way he played it we got the
Queen side closed and here it still
feels it should be winning but it is not
so so so obvious how exactly the engine
gives g4 there is probably stronger to
have to make sure that this is in I
don't think that this cannot work I
think I mean here I'm running out of
moves that I cannot prevent him from
entering him so that is probably winning
them I would have to stay
and then Age 4 and so on
yeah actually this this this yeah and
and it opens up okay so he should go G
for after this I got in aged five and
this is now a little bit more difficult
as G for it's not necessarily winning
anymore even if you get it in I mean the
currently I just take it but like if you
get listen I can take and here I have G
five this particular moment it's really
not a good idea at all to play G forward
I had he played it correctly absolutely
G six back he now has this entry and
something like this and the engine is on
plus three but how does it how does the
engine builders now if I get G foreign
if he gets G fine I probably switches
just to the H file yeah is that the
problem so here here and then G for this
this cake how do you win switch it to
the H file problem look a 4h for yeah go
to the aged father and I mean I'm still
some somehow playing but I don't just
want to understand their this isn't
money one King g8 King if it doubles on
the edge farm and I play Knight to have
seven how do you win them
I mean for example yeah this this this
this
if white now tries to go into the H 12
yeah like this and this and T and here
and whatever this and this doesn't do
much I failed
however I have no movie the right and he
has to see five idea it should be a win
it should be a win ultimately for white
I mean it's it's kind of I'm hanging on
but it should be a winner I cannot
believe it's iterative okay guys thanks
for watching